das war die dümmste aktion in meinem
leben alle freunde viele leute haben mir
gesagt die sommer- auf die website
award.de spielen um ein tolles spiel zu
spielen dann 40 richtig witzig von euch
wie toll die freude wie ich bin heute
das spiel ag.de das hat schon zum bay
toscani palais und viele weitere schon
gezeigt ich bin ein kleiner kreis und
ich nenn mich erstmal irgendwie und
danach zeige ich euch das spiel so dann
haben wir auch schon tolle namen und
zwar heiße ich toilettenpapier und ich
als toilettenpapier muss diese dinge
jetzt hier fressen
damit das ganze ding wächst und ich muss
aufpassen sie nicht von rohr fakt er ist
ja riesig ich bin halt einen punkt und
ich muss andere kleinere punkte fressen
damit ich größer werde und andere
attackieren kann es gibt auch noch
funktionen dass ich mich irgendwie
spalten kann aber ich habe keine ahnung
wie das geht deswegen versuche ich
einfach das spiel zu gewinnen
wahrscheinlich bin ich einfach viel zu
klein und zu tun und kann noch keine
masse verliert ok freunde wir starten
jetzt mal ein experiment hier ist gerade
keiner neben mir wir warten einfach ab
wie lange es dauert bis theoretisch
jemand kommt und mich auffrisst und das
nehmen wir dann als wert dafür um
es liegt am namen freuen denn es liegt
definitiv am namen wenn ich katzenstreu
hat traut sich bestimmt keiner mich
irgendwie anzugreifen
in sich drin ja damit jeder sieht dass
ich der beste bin nenne ich mich fc
barcelona
wir haben die champions league gewonnen
der kann uns nichts der ist doch einfach
viel zu krass was sind das für dinger da
kann ich mich wieder verstecken ist die
beste aller zeiten
das ist unfassbar und jetzt ist niemand
in der nähe die usa kanada ihr mit eurem
blöden aufteilen wieso kann ich das
nicht okay freunde folgendes ziel
ich werde solange irgendwas fressen hier
an der schweiz bis ich so großbauer
folgt bist du riesiges clusaz du direkt
gewonnen aber hier größer als base to
split ok einem youtuber priester ich
kann nicht mehr eingeben freunde das ist
die taktik
ihr müsst einfach sagen dass sie in
youtuber seid dann kann euch nämlich
keiner was dann trotzdem ich keinerlei
anzugreifen gucken die haben ja alle
angst also kummer hier nur weil ich ein
youtuber bin habe ich den steht jetzt
gerade weil ich möchte nur einmal in den
anderen setzen sodass der frist polen
nein das ist mir zu klein ist hut brennt
com einer youtube abließ das schaffen
wir noch england ist viel zu riesig okay
ich glaube ich hab neuen highscore würde
ich mal so grob behaupten also ich denke
dass ich auf einem ganz guten weg bin
das ganze ding
nein mond nein ich denke ich bin auf
einem sehr sehr guten weg das ganze sehr
gut zu beenden
ich werde jetzt ich denke ich kann mich
auch mittlerweile splitten aber das
schauen wir uns gleich mal nicht möchte
nämlich erstmal gerne hier ungarn
fressen oder dich grünen punkt da hinten
einfach kommen bitte lasst mich doch
einmal irgendwen fressen
oh mein gott freund ich bin einfach
schon da ja ich hab mir mal gegessen
ich bin zum zu a nein nein wieso hab ich
mich dann nochmal gesplittet das war die
dümmste aktion in meinem leben ja neben
der aktion dass ich dachte dass ich mit
dem longboard supertollen berg
runterfahren kann ich mich danach mega
gemault habt oder als ich dachte dass
ich beim jetski fahren doch einfach mal
versuchen könnte ein handstand machen
übrigens hier da hab ich immer noch eine
wunde von wälder seen herum und wissen
was freunde ich lebe immer noch und
wisst ihr warum einfach weil ich ein
youtuber bin eine youtuber places
eigentlich sollte da noch dort und ihm
ihr seid ihr alle wieder riesig
ganz viele punkte ganz viel und seid ja
alle rivel scheiße die königin verfolgt
nicht ankommt ich erstmal hier am namen
der comdirect in meinen mund rein jetzt
damit ich mir noch ein paar trotz und
dann freudig jetzt das kann nicht sein
ich habe überlebt dieses spiel macht so
viel spaß ich will das wars mit diesem
video wenn die eventuellen zweiten teil
ag.de ihr sehen wollt dann nehme ich
locker keinen auf fans trotzdem gefallen
hat würde ich mich über eine bewertung
freundlich